Hello again, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters, session 9 of our cancer class, and we were talking about
different things to do with cancer. Today, I'm going to talk about
things that literally put the brakes on your immune system, and that is
chronic stress, or even acute stress for that matter, but doing some statistics on chronic stress.
So what stress does to you? First of all, stress initiates the sympathetic nervous system.
So, from a neurological standpoint, you have two pieces of your nervous system,
you have your voluntary, and your involuntary, your voluntary. I want to lift my leg,
your involuntary, meaning you don't have to think about your heart to beat. You don't have to know
what your liver does, and it still doesn't. That involuntary nervous system is called your
autonomic nervous system, so think of it as your automatic nervous system. Now, the purpose of
the autonomic nervous system is to control all your organ function. The autonomic nervous system is
split into two opposing sides. What is your sympathetic nervous system, and what is your
parasympathetic nervous system? Your parasympathetic nervous system controls all your digestion,
your sexual function, your detoxification, your immune system. Your rest relaxation helps wash your
brain while you're sleeping, helps increase lymph flow. Everything you can think of that would be
positive is your parasympathetic nervous system. Now, it doesn't mean your sympathetic is a bad thing,
but it's only supposed to be for a purpose. So your parasympathetic controls all those good things,
your sympathetic controls the fight or flight mechanism. Some people call it the fight
flight or freeze mechanism because that's what could happen with your body when you encounter a
giant crisis. So when you have a perceived crisis or a real crisis, it doesn't make it a different.
So if a polar bear jumps out in front of you, or you think there's a polar bear
on in front of you, you will have a sympathetic nervous system response. That would be actually
normal. So that polar bear jumps out in front of you, you need a sympathetic nervous system response.
Well, guess what happens with a sympathetic response? You shut down detoxification, you shut
down digestion, shut down any sexual function. We don't need to reproduce. We got a polar bear in
front of us. We don't need to detox. We got a polar bear that is going to eat us. Who cares if I
going to die of mercury poisoning in five years? I'm going to get eaten by a polar bear right now.
Everything parasympathetic is shut down. Your sympathetic kick-in. So that dilates your eyes,
so you can see where to run away, shuts blood to your extremities, increases your blood pressure,
opens up your brokial tubes, and you are able to flee into survive. So it's everything that's involved
in a survival mechanism. Now the problem is, is that we live in a culture where we are sympathetic
dominant. We live in a culture where, though we are not running away from polar bears,
our bodies are acting like we're running away from a polar bear all the time. We're in this
chronic, ribbed-up stress environment. So our braid is fired, a sympathetic nervous system
response all the time. So the slide shows a cute little droid about a man and a woman there,
and it says that stress of cancer alone causes a sympathetic response. That is exactly true.
So you don't go into the doctor and hear, yes, you have sorry, but this lump in your rest,
we found it to be cancerous. It's stage two, and we need to do surgery and radiation. I don't think
anybody's response has been cool. That's just fantastic. All right, when do we get started? This
is going to be fun. What an experience. I'm always up for an adventure. No. You end up with a
fear-based sympathetic response. You wouldn't be normal if you didn't. This is a survival mechanism
that's going on, except running away from a polar bear is not going to help this situation.
So every chemical that you make into your body during a sympathetic response is
completely anti to what you really need in order to heal from a chronic disease like cancer.
So even the knowledge of your cancer and try to come to a decision in your treatment program,
and you having fear about that is making enough chemicals that is fueling the growth of your cancer.
So when we tell our patients over and over again, you have got to get a handle of the stress part.
You have to get a handle of the fear. You cannot think that you are going to heal from
cancer growing in your body and you being in a state of terror. It's just not going to work.
You have to get a handle of this. That's why we like to do some spiritual counseling here too.
If you don't aren't able to turn this over to the Lord and know that you are in His hands and you
know that you know that you know that where you're going when you die, then you can ever have total
peace about this. That's why the Bible is very clear that we are supposed to have a peace that
passes all understanding. That means in the midst of trouble, we are going to have trouble.
That is a promise in Scripture that we're going to have trouble, but we have to know that he
overcame that trouble. Chronic stress, here's a nice cool diagram how prostate cancer could be
any cancer that we're talking about. That itself, the knowledge of the cancer causes stress will stress
feeds the prostate cancer. On the top of that diagram, it says HPA, that's your hypothermic pituitary
access. That stress is felt at that part of the brain, deeper the brain where your pituitary
gland gland is and your hypothalamus stimulates your pituitary gland, then stimulates your adrenal
production and literally shuts down a poptosis, so it causes the cancer to continue to grow.
Chronic stress also increases what's called TH2 immune system. It's the side of the immune system
that makes antibodies, so that's not the side of the immune system that you need to kill cancer.
You want a hyper-TH1 response to kill cancer cells. Chronic stress tips the balance of your
immune response that should be a balanced TH1, TH2, and when you're fighting disease, you want it
a little hyper-TH1, when you're dealing with cancer. It's tips into the balance of a hyper-TH2.
One of the reasons why I say that all cancer has an autoimmune component,
in all people, their cancer, they are TH2 dominant at the side of the cancer. That's why the cancer,
one of the reasons why the cancer is allowed to continue to grow.
Chronic stress increases suppressor T cell production by the tumor itself, so the tumor itself
as it grows, starts to secrete its own suppressor T cells that starts destroyed your immune cells.
That's not good. It causes lymphocyte apoptosis, meaning that your own lymphocytes,
your own white blood cells that are trying to kill the cancer start to die, because it op regulates
the death-legged, the FAS death-legged in the lymphocytes themselves, so it increases the death of
your TH1 cells. It creates a TH2 imbalance, dominance at the side of the cancer, and it helps
your cancer cells to create their own immune cells that kill your immune system. It's a huge
negative cycle that you have to break. Chronic stress increases the growth and proliferation of
the testesis of cancer through this and other things. It also does what other really bad thing.
It increases what's called VEGF production. VEGF is vascular edithelial growth factor. It's
actually a chemical that's made in a chronic stress situation. It's made in other situations too,
but for the sole purpose of increasing vascularity, think of it this way. Why would
chronic stress increase vascularity to a tissue? Well, if I'm in a chronic stress state,
I'm having to run away from polar bears all the time. It would be better to increase my vascularity
into my heart, increase my vascularity into muscle tissue, so I have an increased blood flow to that
area, so next time I will be able to run away from that polar bear even better.
But when we're dealing with cancer, so I already have cancer, and oh, I have chronic stress,
you do not want to increase vascular edithelial growth factor and vascularize a cancer. So,
if I vascularize a tuber, if my body will increase growth of due blood vessels into a tuber,
you are increasing that tuber's ability to feed. And when that tuber can feed,
then it can, it just grows, you know, exponentially. So, the biggest thing that you could do to get
rid of your cancer is to get a handle on your chronic stress. You have to deal with this terror.
You have to settle in your heart that you're okay with the results of whatever treatment you're
choosing, regardless of what the results are. And to the degree that you're able to settle with
those results is to the degree that you're going to decrease all, production of all these chemicals
that are going to feed your cancer. It's really hard for me to do all sorts of things from a
nutraceutical standpoint and from a rife standpoint to help this person with cancer when they come in
every time and they're in just like terror all the time. It's like, you might as well be pouring
gasoline on your cancer cells because that's literally what's happening. Some statistics,
breast cancer risk doubled after marriage issues, divorce issues, relationship issues, severe stress with
minimal social support, increase breast cancer risk, occurrence, dying fold.
Breast cancer increases, cancer increases after chronic depression too. So emotional situations
just put all this negative chemicals that feed cancers. And you, this is something you need to
get counseling, you need to seek outside help. If you have relationship issues, you need to get
counseling with this. You have to get in a safe place. You need to be in a situation where you
can be in peace with what's going on. Psalm 56 says, When I'm afraid, I will trust in you. In God
whose word I praise, in God I trust, I will not be afraid. What can mortal man do for me?
Do to me and you can change mortal man and you can say anything that this world has. What can it do
to me? The beauty of this verse is that it talks about, it doesn't say that I will never be afraid
when I'm a believer and it doesn't mean that I'll never go through struggles and it doesn't mean
that I'm never going to have fear and I'm never going to have stress and I'm never going to worry
about the future and I'm never going to worry about what's going to happen to my kids. It says,
When I'm afraid, it just is honest. It says that I am afraid. We're not talking about not being
human. We're not talking about not being honest with what's going on inside your heart, but we're
talking about being honest and laying it on the table. This scares me to death. I am really worried
about this and being and laying it out there so that you can deal with it now so you can see it
and you're not stuffing it. The scares me. I'm worried about it. What if this happens? What if I die?
What if I suffer this way? What is going to happen to my kids? That is the saddest way to deal with it.
I do not think it's healthy for a person even if they come to us and they're a believer and they
start saying, well, God's going to take this away so I'm not going to talk about it anymore. God's
just taking this cancer away and I don't even have the cancer. It's good. In one sense, that positive
outlook can be helpful because the person is focused on the good and that's what we would. But
another sense, it can be a crutch because we're not honestly dealing with the humanness of what's
going on in our life. It is never fun to struggle. It is never fun to have pain in our life. It is never
fun to have a serious diagnosis and I don't think it's healthy to stick our head this way and pretend
that it doesn't occur. We need to be honest with ourselves. I'm scared. I don't know what to do. I need
help. This is where we need that interdependence of family and loving relationships to come around us
and be that support system for us. In the program, you'll see a download of a PDF that's called
My Hope Heart Condition Workbook. That heart condition workbook is there for you. Regardless of whether
you have cancer or a loved one is struggling with some other disease or you have just some chronic
fatigue, it is super helpful because our belief here is that you cannot bury emotions and you can
hide them behind some ultra-spiritual perspective that you might have. You have to be honest and
human and there's all sorts of things that has happened to us over the course of our lifetime
that can set us up for just deep, hidden emotional scars. It can be something that our parents did
with no ill intent, but it's the way my six-year-old mind accepted that, that my father said
or my mother said or my teacher did. So it's not about casting blame, it's not about being the victim.
Matter of fact, it is absolutely not about being the victim, but it's about taking responsibility
and going, okay, where are my deep-hidden hurts? Where are my deep-seated emotions that I maybe
stuffed years and years ago? This heart condition workbook will help you uncover them. There's several
tests that you want to take through that. Work through it. Be honest, have a time that it's just
quiet. If you have kids do it when they're in bed, do it when it's just you and the Lord and just
ask the Holy Spirit to reveal the answers to you, to reveal maybe hidden things in your heart that
you have a dealt with. It's very common that some root causes of all sorts of diseases that we have
have emotional ties. Matter of fact, I would argue that every disease that we have, every illness,
we have every problem that we're going through has some deep spiritual or emotional connection to it
that we may not even be aware of in our current reality. But so we need to ask the Holy Spirit to
bring that out to lay it on the table. This workbook is meant to help open up those doors. So go
through this workbook, fill out those problems. It's very self-explanatory. Take your time to go
through that and see what God has for you. And if there's people you need to forgive, you need to
forgive them. If there's people you need to ask for forgiveness from, you need to ask for forgiveness
from people. If there's things that you did wrong in your life, if there's sin that's that's
covered up that you haven't dealt with, that you haven't repented of, that you haven't laid on the
table before God because you're too ashamed of. He already knows about it. So lay it on the table.
He already loves you. He's already forgiven you. If you were the last person on earth and Jesus
came today, he would still go to the cross and die so that he could be reconciled with you and you
could spend eternity with him forever and ever. I truly believe that. That's how much he loves you.
So go at it with that understanding that you are already loved. You're already forgiven. He's
just beckoning you to climb up on his lap so he can hold you and tell you everything's going to be
all right. All right. We're going to talk a lot about this in the my quiet place.
But I did need to touch on it when we're talking about kids are here. Hope this is beneficial and I'll
see you next week.